I do want to acknowledge I'm sure many
people know this but February of course
is Black History Month it's a it's a
great opportunity to look back on the
history of african-americans but this is
our thing there are current day stories
that African Americans have to tell that
are just as inspiring as the stories of
historic figures so here once again to
share with us one of his inspirational
tales is writer Deon Cole in a segment
he calls black his stories
[Applause]
[Music]
one night I went to a club here in Los
Angeles and I was the only black guy
online when I got into the door the
bouncers here you can't get in with
those jeans on and I said why not you've
been letting them people with jeans on
and he said we're we're not anymore so I
stood there wondering what to do next
before young underage white girls walked
up to me thinking of the security and
showed me four phony IDs screaming at me
hurry up so I let the girls in the club
then I called the police and told them
the club had underage girls in it but
then one hour the police came and ended
the party arrested the girls and shut
the club down for good thank you racism
[Applause]
behind Paul everybody that was in place
the Black Power salute backing up that's
how he leaves everything behind he's
been injured so many time doing a stares
its peripheral visions very bad